all right we're told that the arithmetic
sequence a sub I is defined by the
formula where the eighth term in the
sequence is going to be four plus three
times I minus one what is a sub 20 and
so a sub 20 is the 20th term in the
sequence and I encourage you to pause
the video and figure out what is the
20th term well we can just think about
it like this a sub 20 we just use this
definition of the I term everywhere we
see an i we would put a 20 in so it's
going to be 4 plus 3 times 20 minus 1 so
once again just to be clear a sub 20
where instead of a sub i wherever we saw
an i we put 20 and now we can just
compute what this is going to be equal
to this is going to be equal to 4 plus 3
times 20 minus 1 is 19 3 times 19 let's
see 3 times 19 is 57 right is 30 plus 27
yep this is 57 and 4 plus 57 is equal to
61
so the 20th term in this arithmetic
sequence is going to be 61 let's do
another one of these and here they've
told us the arithmetic sequence a sub I
is defined by the formula a sub 1 to
give us the first term and they say
every other term so a sub I they're
defining it in terms of the previous
term so a sub I is going to be a sub I
minus 1 minus 2 so this is actually a
recursive definition of our arithmetic
sequence so let's see what we can make
of this so a sub 5 a sub 5 is going to
be equal to we'll use this second line
right here a sub 5 is going to be equal
to a sub 4 minus 2 but we don't know
what a sub 4 is just yet so let's try to
figure that out so we could say that a
sub 4 is equal to well if we use the
second line again it's going to be a sub
3 minus 2 we still don't know what a sub
3 is I'll keep switching colors because
it looks nice a sub 3
is going to be equal to a sub 3-1 so a
sub 2 minus 2 we don't we still don't
know what a sub 2 is and so we could
write a sub 2 is equal to a sub 2 minus
1 so that's a sub 1 minus 2 now luckily
we know what a sub 1 is a sub 1 is
negative 7 a sub 1 is negative 7 so if
this is negative 7 then a sub 2 is
negative 7 minus 2 which is equal to
negative 9 well that starts helping us
out because if a sub 2 is negative 9 if
this is negative 9 then a sub 3 is
negative 9 minus 2 which is equal to
negative 11 well now that we know that a
sub 3 is negative 11 so this is negative
11 we could figure out a sub 4 is
negative 11 minus 2 which is equal to
negative 13 and we're almost there we
know a sub 4 the fourth term in this
arithmetic sequence is negative 13 so we
can now so this is negative 13 a sub 5
is going to be a sub 4 which is negative
13 minus 2 which is equal to negative 15
so the fifth term in the sequence is
negative 15 and we're all done